[Music]
our first headline comes from the
onion dying gazin criticized for not
using last words to condemn Hamas that
was a funny one we can start with this
Victor do you condemn
Hamas oh God uh I think it's silly to
condemn things um but do I think like uh
what they what they did with was mostly
bad
yeah that isn't the that isn't the
response I expected yeah do I think
Hamas is a bad organization yeah mostly
I do Eric do you condemn Hamas I mean I
guess I guess condemnation is like an
official position when you're somebody
important nobody's really looking at me
to make those kinds of uh
gestures
so I mean it's kind of just irrelevant
but I mean just performative condemn is
a it is a public speech act I have
trouble expressing approval of murdering
civilians of course obviously I do have
a lot of problems with any kind of
violence but I mean the historical
complexity of these things is immense
and I'm not an expert so you know
there's the there's the kind of
condemnation where it's just a very
immediate reaction to a very immediate
thing and you have this gut feeling that
something wrong has happened and I mean
fine you're probably right but you got
to look at the complicated history of
these things
and sure whatever that's my cop out and
they just need to get Gaza out of the
way so that they can move onto the land
acknowledgement phase of genocide like
us this is a pat episode right no it's
not no it's not okay well in that case I
do condemn him
to us Advanced Colonial Nations who've
who've got a much longer history with
these kinds of things yeah I mean Israel
seems to be heading in that direction do
you condemn
cannibalism uh what if the person if the
person uh so I do I don't actually I
think that if you as long as it doesn't
involve The Killing I I make a
distinction between eating a human and
killing a human I think if the human's
already dead or voluntarily died uh I'm
not sure that I know uh that it matters
that's what I was going to ask about
because what if your plane crashed in
the Andes Mountains and the only way to
survive the only way to survive the only
way to survive is to eat your goalie no
it's not a movie this happened in the so
like the soccer CH I think I saw the
movie I mean what's it called alive yeah
with um Ethan Hawk I think well movies
come first and reality follows and the
in the film the guy said eat me if I die
didn't he to it yeah yeah the moralism
case I I want I think this is a place
where theory is actually at its best and
at its most useful because what this is
turned into is the do you condemn Hamas
question is a moralist question which is
who is good who is evil how do I align
myself with the good as opposed to the
evil and the moralist case here is that
evil is a cause so evil causes certain
actions and good causes other actions
instead of asking the actual important
question which is what is causal or the
the Lumen the Lumen question is the
distinction between good and evil good
is it a good distinction to make or is
it an evil distinction to make like when
knowledge of the they ate from the Tree
of the knowledge of Good and Evil and
they were cast out from Eden because
that was a bad distinction to become
familiar with so according to according
to lum's reading of Genesis yeah well
systems theory is going to be lurking in
the background but there's a there's one
side of the issue that will say
colonizers do things because they are
evil and that's wrong and then exactly
the flip side because these these
circulate themselves through
communication into binaries the other
moralists will believe that the
colonized do things because they are
evil and that's also wrong and I thought
that everyone kind of knew this but our
communication apparatus in the pr War
side of the war is bizarrely dependent
on this manakian divide of of Good and
Evil which of course doesn't help
anything it's extremely parochial that's
why Star Wars is has such an enduring
influence cuz it he constructed a kind
of a fantasy manakan Universe with the
force is good and evil and then somehow
there's kind of like a neutral Force I
don't know how that kind of works
there's the sort of a new thing they're
exploring but I mean yeah we we got to
see this uh this sort of Journey of
Anakin becoming Darth Vader and then
redeeming himself by throwing the
emperor off but now he's completely
forgiven even though Our Generation was
exposed to the trauma of seeing Hayden
Christensen murdering children on the
screen pretty clearly and now he's a
good guy again do you condemn Hayden
Christensen I condemn the character I
feel bad for his career I don't know
what else he did since uh Star Wars he's
back in Star Wars again haven't you seen
Ahsoka let me stop you there because
While most people's morality is
processed by either Disney or Harry
Potter today we're reading France fenon
on violence and it's applicable to the
last two weeks of propaganda for sure
and the first lesson I guess of
propagandizing violence is to
dehumanizing or dehumanize your enemy by
accusing them particularly of a Hands-On
type of violence you know raping women
killing babies and it's interesting that
you brought this up because it's always
perceived as worse when as worse
violence when Anakin killed children
with his hands as opposed to you know
ordering the Death Star to blow up a
planet so personalized violence makes
you a beast and this has been War
propaganda from time immemorial it's in
the Bible even when the Babylonians or
Assyrians whatever they they roll up and
start smashing baby heads but it's
important to propaganda and it's used as
as justification for the Gulf War even
early 90s even though it was completely
made up but the Iraqi Army started
throwing babies out of incubators was
the big the big line now it does happen
probably does it not in this case I
don't know but at least for fan and the
conflicts that he's speaking about this
personal Hands-On violence is often the
only type that the repressed or
colonized people has access to not the
impersonal violence of drone striking an
apartment building from a thousand met
up or or what he calls abstract violence
which is you know day-to-day coercion
forced movement uh their surveillance
usually backed up by an imperial power
yeah I guess that's a decent enough
place to start is that there's
typification of different moral and less
moral types of violence that always
favors the oppressor and allows them to
cast resistance as barbaric and Savage
and inhuman but the Death Star killed
way more kids than the light saber did
but it it doesn't hit the same way
psychologically speaking what's the
opposite of personal violence is it just
like a generalized kind of violence like
a like kind of like looking at like
there's a war going on it's violent or
there's like violence being perpetrated
against peoples and and and and groups
and things like a less yeah being less
specific or not
mentioning sort of details of gruesome
things but just sort of saying there's a
general situation of of of horror and
suppression the depersonalization of
violence means you push a button and
people die so the process is mediated so
it's a more it's a more humane way for
the killer to kill where they don't you
know see the effects of their actions oh
I see almost like the firing squad where
sort of nobody really know knows who
shot the killing exactly even more
removed than that that's the evolution
of you know not giving your own soldiers
PTSD is to make make it so they don't
know whether they did The Killing it's
kind of like an a moral insulation or
something like that or kind even
psychological and this is kind of what
this is what fenon calls abstract
violence is the state performs or the
state in a in a colonial situation their
violence is abstract in the sense that
it is filtered through um whatever
values laws rules it's bureaucratized so
that you can't really hold the person
responsible that's part of the
difficulty I think of reading fenan
without a very kind of deep
understanding of of this situation that
he's writing in which is the Algerian
struggle for Independence yeah
decolonization he's like a psychologist
right he's treating I don't know if you
got to the end of the book but he's just
they're just case studies lists of case
studies of him
treating soldiers and uh you know people
that
were that that witness that were witness
to incredible violence and they're
experiencing psychosis and these other
symptoms so I mean this isn't just an an
abstract Theory text he's he's
practicing and trying to s through this
by establishing a theory of violence
yeah I got that sense it's very much
looking at at kind of psychology and
culture and the kind of mentality around
all of this as well he's not just I mean
it's he's very far from just giving a
very a kind of a factual account of his
I mean a lot of it is
firsthand his experience but um a lot of
it is yeah almost
psychoanalytic and and social analysis
can we run through some local news real
quick and and I do I do mean real quick
but I I think so I watch about an hour
of news per
week on the StairMaster because the
StairMaster has a TV on it um but our I
think we got some we got some good mask
off liberal Democratic consensus
reality this
week um and I'm going to call out you
know
these supposed Progressive
institutions specifically in
Canada and I know this is going on
everywhere but we'll just we'll just
locate ourselves specifically in Canada
so the Ontario NDP this is the first one
our socialis is party you know in name
only forced a retraction from a
representative you I'm sorry I'm not
from here what do you call the Ontario
representatives in the in the Ontario
Parliament MPP member of provincial
Parliament okay MPP sounds right to me
uh but they forced a retraction from an
N um
MPP in which she called for an end of
all occupation of Palestinian land and
an end to a partide um and they said
that the party does not agree with her
statements because they are anti-semitic
and discrimin discriminatory oh that's
ridiculous but I mean if you look at
this through like a lumen lens though I
I feel like it it makes perfect sense
like uh you can't really like for all
the different geopolitical kind of
intertwined relationships like a
political party that's vying for real
power in a in a liberal democracy like
Canada there's limits to the kinds of
positions they can take on the Israel
Palestine situation which has nothing to
do with morality and has everything to
do with like interests and relationships
I mean yeah a lot of their a lot of what
they're doing is with what their
opposition is then going to do and say
after that is what they have in mind and
and obviously yeah looking forward to
elections and and and at the national
level too what how their behavior
reflects on the on the federal party Etc
yeah I mean that's that's how you got to
kind of look at it and then how it kind
of comes into contact with you know
economics and the legal system and
things like that and especially
international law right that's the a lot
of people love to just observe this
whole situation from the perspective of
international law which is important but
a little bit anemic if you're just using
that lens I think we've I think we've
seen that international law doesn't make
a of difference when it comes to
the United States even Canada
Israel um oh it's a framework for making
observations about these situations
right it's not a solution to anything
it's just just an agreed upon framework
through which you can discuss these
situations according to rules and
precedents I mean Absolut before we get
too moral about this I I should say the
only reason that this even matters the
reason that there's moral outrage and we
care about it is because it's on Twitter
like what 300 reaction machine 300,000
people were killed in Yemen with $15
billion of Canadian equipment
and it's not like I batted an eyelash
about that and Amnesty International
said it was a violation of international
law but you know what am I going to do
that's the other side of personalizing
violence or or and depersonalizing
violence is the way that social media is
very personalized now because the
algorithms right they you know they
track your behavior and they suggest
things they think you'll like so you end
up getting very personal suggestions so
if you're depending on what kind of
perspective you tend to look at that's
the one you're going to be shown and so
it's very also very
individualized very
personalized so if you tend to like a
more maybe intellectual perspective
maybe you're just going to get like
Chomsky interviews and if not you're
going to get other things and that's the
kind of flip side of
of personalizing violence is is that you
have a personalized Newsfeed and
whatever you want is going to be on
there
but again yeah it's it's a very
presentist reactionary kind of not
reactionary just it's a reaction right
it's this happened now react to it all
right now we have a social media thing
going on a phenomenon all right so we
were also glazing up uh Olivia Chow as
being a progressive who was elected uh a
couple months ago and we were
celebrating that but then there was a
pro
Palestinian rally in Nathan Phillips
Square which she declared was
deplorable well there you go our
Progressive candidate again same thing
as the last example not surprising I
think if there is a difference though
it's she doesn't have a party brass to
appease she's just a mayor well it you
know what I I hear I mean I have
listened to Chomsky lately because I
know he's an expert on on the Israel
Palestine situation and
um yeah like What He tends to say is
that is that young liberals young young
younger people tend to be you know more
sympathetic towards Palestine whereas
maybe older people especially on the
Republican side tend to be more friendly
towards Israel and um kind of steering
Israel into in in this direction of of
being a kind of well it has very their
support for Israel does have very
anti-semitic roots in itself the
Evangelical Community is very
anti-semitic and Israel
the support for Israel is very ironic
but it's very real as well and and maybe
there islamophobia trumps their
anti-Semitism but it's it's all kind of
connected well final
example which I think uh parades itself
in most other cases as Canada's most
left leaning school but it condemned
three student
groups um for expressing solidarity with
pales pal
saying in response that freedom of
expression has limits oh yeah yeah
freedom of expression is I mean the
limits are making people feel unsafe
that's the the limit which is now that's
something I'd like to see play out in
court
because pretty inflammatory it you know
talks about uh it describes like the
attack on on civilians as a an
expression of like resistance against
like uh like like kind of whitewashing
it a little bit and then also was saying
a bunch of stuff about like they were
like socalled Canada which cracked me up
it kind of reminds me of Contra points'
whole problem with Academia so-called
isra socalled isra so but they also said
so-called Canada in the statement
they're like socalled Canada continues
to to support or whatever Israel and all
that stuff it was fun it was a funny
statement just like that is funny um out
of touch activists out of touch with the
broad population of can look I'm going
to say on a on a significant ation level
so-called Canada is is better than
Canada you know yeah sure I agree if we
are doing some systems theory here
then you have to say these are
interconnected bureaucracies of
communication management that don't
necessarily all yield a single thing but
I'm sure they didn't mean it that way in
any case um if you've been uh I don't
know jerking off to your own philosophy
of resistance which uh it looks like has
about which posts are morally Justified
we can get back to that later if you're
reading how TV has rendered the entire
world a bardian simulation you can get
back to that later also because I mean
at least for me this kind of seems to be
where the rubber meets the road because
our
states Canada America and Europe except
Ireland you can get back to all of that
after but if you want to like look at
where Theory rubber meets the road this
seems to be where it is what do you mean
by
that excuse me keep that in my god
dude well for for example if you want to
know how an ideological State apparatus
functions in tandem with a repressive
State
apparatus here you have examples if you
want to look at how performative speech
acts function like
condemn um how these words function in
place of politics to maintain the status
quo here are your examples and
especially if you're a career academic
masturbating to your philosophy of
resistance and yet trting out all the
same lines as the globin male in the
middle of a pretty pretty public
genocide then you're the case study and
I like before before I morally soapbox
myself I should say I've never done
anything to help any
Palestinian I'm I'm as indifferent as
anyone else because I'm sitting here in
my comfy gamer chair but still the the
screen in front of this is it's
it's
egregious yeah I mean I guess when the
chips are
down but Theory tends to be very
backward looking as well it's like I I I
don't advocate theory is a way of
predicting the future in any substantive
way but it is it is a tool for for
looking at history and and starting with
learning about history is is a very good
place to go so that's one of the
Humanity's disciplines right history
philosophy literature or kind of the old
school core so I mean that's when you
hear Chomsky speak right he goes into
massive amounts of historical detail not
just cuz he has this I don't know
amazing memory or and this commitment to
these issues but he he sets things in
historical context always which is the
complete opposite of experience of
reading the mainstream media is
everything is like what's happening
right now and and and all eyes are on
everybody and how they're reacting to it
and and that's that's a very stifling
kind of situation to make analysis in
because everyone's constantly looking at
you to see what kind of moral position
they can derive from what you're saying
even if you're very carefully trying to
just be very factual you're going to be
perceived as you know Pro or anti evil
or good whatever right and I mean that's
not conducive to good analyses of
situations it's just not and that's not
what the media is supposed to do anyway
it's in-depth analysis of situation
and I would like to say that this is
very much a an observation of
observation because the media does
observation especially and especially in
terms of language and linguistic
analysis so the word like terrorist is
very loaded I learned in grade 10 social
studies that one man's terrorist is
another man's Freedom Fighter this is
one of these uh trope perspectival again
it's a Trope but it's being uh cashed
out again here we
unequivocally
decry you know we unequivocally
equivocate about
this we will not equivocate
unequivocally yeah I mean the terrorist
charge is is is a little
bit I mean it was it it's appropriate I
think in one at one level it's a terror
it's meant it's a terror attack and
another level it's being used as
justification for other things right and
again in a kind of
ahistorical manner right it's like we we
here during the Afghanistan war as if
you f follow those sorts of things about
who was trained in the United States and
who the United States created and what
their responsibility for it all of
course as the situation is unfolding
yeah the states are going in there to
rescue people from Evil T tyrannical
like dictatorships and things and then
years later horrific comes out and
the whole situation looks like it was
just the US was just the bad guy the
whole time and I I think
situation is going to be the same right
I mean relatively
speaking in in terms of of a of an of a
conflict not not Universal goodness or
evil but in terms of a conflict they
tend to be the aggressors which we tend
to consider to be the not so good
position position to be in right right
they it but this will come out later
right now everything is floating in this
In This Cloud of of extreme emotion and
obscurity and lack of details and so
many cross lines of
communication and then in the future
it's going to come out but by
then it's too late like what's happened
is
happens and if you don't learn from
these things then you're doomed to
repeat thumbs another another platitude
another
truism so why don't we look at the text
then it's France
fenon um beginning of wretched of the
earth which is probably his second most
famous book and the first bit of this is
on violence so I wanted to look at on
violence just to see if we
could cut through some of the
that feels like we're in a delirium of
uh moral posturing in every possible way
so
Fan's educated in Psychiatry that's like
his his main job I guess but he's
also or he was also fighting in World
War II in martinque I guess in the
Caribbean uh with a free French which is
against uh what was the vichi French
regime so he was on the good guys side
you could
say and he he a contemporary of French
intellectuals you probably heard of like
sart toir uh
laon influenced greatly by uh merlu
ponti and we have to go back to
Alexander Kev at least for a second
because he's very much indebted to kev's
interpretation of Hegel from the
phenomenology of spirit which is
recognition and he applies this
primarily to Colonial situations and
primarily to the Colonial situation in
Algeria justifying I would say
justifying violence not saying that
violence is like a a good because he
doesn't use those terms at all but just
saying that it's absolutely
understandable why a colonized subject
would for the sake of being recognized
as a subject would carry out acts of
violence yeah and that there's a sense
in which he's he's saying the colonial
Situation's already rif with
violence right
like colonialism is inherently violent
and decolonialization is going to be no
different it's also inherently
violent you know these these revolutions
I
mean you know you have he's he's also
writing the wretch of the earth and the
Cuban Revolution is happening and and
and the independence of of other nations
Morocco Tunisia
Sudan and and you have the the French
campaign I believe in Vietnam which was
the precursor for the for the US
takeover of that and the the Battle of
Dian ban Fu and the French the French
campaign in in Vietnam where they were
defeated right so all of these things
are floating around in the background
and of course he's in his place with the
The Liberation movement there um and
he's yeah I mean he didn't he died not
too long after this came out but he's
writing Reflections and a kind of
continuing his theorizing of this and
violence is just yeah like the colonial
situation we already mentioned it's a
manikian he call he he calls it this the
colonization kind of or colonialism
turns everything into a kind of manikian
Universe where good and evil charges of
Good and Evil are going all over the
place again here and I don't know this
is something I learned when I was just
researching for this episode but after I
mean it's relevant to now but s wrote
the S wrote the introduction to this
book and because of sart's support for
The Six Day War which was the 67 Israel
Arab War um France Fan's
wife wanted to get rid of sart's
introduction so he he got he got
cancelled for his Pro Zionist attitudes
that she felt were incompatible with her
husband's work yeah like I mean the
French intellectuals have been kind of
famous for the positions they've taken
on some of this stuff like Fuko as well
I think I think he was in support of um
Iran at one point um I'm not super
familiar with it all I'd have to look it
up
again um but this leads up to I guess
Fan's take on the dialectic of
recognition which is to say yeah this is
all well and good for like white people
to write about phenomenology and how one
comes to be a subject but because I'm
black and because I'm from the the
periphery of the Empire I'll never be a
subject in the eyes of French society
and this is this this became the book of
black skin white masks um which says not
only do French subjects see black French
subjects as secondary but black French
subjects also see themselves as
secondary that everything white stands
on the side of civilization rationality
culture and everything black stands on
the side of the irrational and the
Primitive and no matter what you ACC in
your life like he's an accomplished
academic intellectual in Paris but you
you're always going to be haunted by
your status of recognition as other and
the only solution to that is to fight
because fighting with violence is the
only way to be free you can't be given
your freedom because if you accept the
gift of Freedom then the other will
never recognize you the the other will
will only recognize you in
self-determination which in his view uh
requires a sort of violence he says for
instance near the beginning the the
colonized who have been who have made up
their mind to make such an agenda into a
driving force that is decolonization and
disorder they have been prepared for
violence from time
immemorial as soon as they are born it
is obvious to them that their cramped
World riddled with taboos can only be
challenged by out and out
violence yeah call that justification if
you want it seems to me he's just
commenting on the inevitability of it
you you're born into a world of violence
and violence seems like the only option
you really
have and I noticed he doesn't he doesn't
really specify violence against whom
it's usually just you know Colonial
violence Colonial
violence you know the kind of cycle of
violence right you know the tip fortat
kind of violence you know you you
committed an atrocity against us now
we're going to commit something against
you and it's a cycle it's a cycle of
violence and he talks about the
compartmentalization of the colonial
world into
these I mean Baba homie Baba comments on
this saying that this is an interesting
kind of spatial
understanding of of colonialism too so
the spatial understanding of violence
you know the the compartmentalization of
the colonial world into into certain
areas where the natives go and then the
areas where the where the Europeans are
supposed to go or the the colonists are
supposed to be you know conducting their
activities and they become almost like
separate worlds but they're looking at
each other they're not unaware of each
other's presence and there's this play
of of of animosity antagonism and and
envy even in Ina in some cases he
doesn't he doesn't restrain from saying
things that you know you know the the
colonized Envy the colonizer things
things like that he he he's going into
his his psychoanalytic kind of framework
with that and looking at the the M the
mindset I guess you could say the
mentality that is developed in these
situations I don't know I don't want to
go all the way to the the end point
where we say speech is
violence you know cuz that gets a little
bit cringe but to say that violence is
speech is something I think that I'd
agree with but liberalism to me the
great Insight of it is that state
governance is not based on gods or
nature on God who founded the state at
some point in time immemorial like the
state was founded by Vi every state was
founded by violence and Victor you have
to correct me on this it's either lock
or Hobs but who said we have a primal
right to violence that's one of our most
basic
rights and your basic right then you
rent to the state you rent it out so
that the state can do the violence on
your behalf for the purpose of stability
and
security but can lock probably said it
to but you can always take it back right
you can take it back if the state is not
holding its end up in terms of well that
part's that part's lock okay well also
Hobs kind of says that because he says
that the only circumstance in which you
can uh rebel against the go against The
Sovereign is if they are violating your
most important natural right which is
really just uh like self security like
so if they're going to kill you or
something
yeah I feel like by the time you get to
mills's on on Liberty that violence is
is supposed to be taken over by the
legal system basically you're not
supposed to go you know challenge
someone who's wronged you to a duel
anymore by that point you're and and
shoot them on the streets you're
supposed to appeal to the courts or
something like that to to resolve this
situation
non-violently or at least you're
supposed to yeah yeah they subsidized
violence for you well you have the
original act of violence and then you
have a whole bunch of bureaucratic
institutions that take its place so you
you have to go through the appropriate
channels but I kind of agree with this
point in liberalism is that if the
channels do not work for you as I
believe they don't work for the people
of Gaza then if violence is the last
type of speech or the type of
communication that you can
perform then
yeah I don't want to use the word
justification but you can understand why
no other type of speech works so this is
the type of speech that remains and this
but this isn't going to work
either it's actually going to make
things worse like strategically it's a
terrible move but it's just giving
Israel all the justification to be even
more brutal but you're supposing that
there's another world in which this
justification didn't exist and then they
sought a different solution which they
so Fan's point is like by using violence
like the colonizer gets to see their
humanity and their subjectivity it's
like I feel like this is doing the
opposite like if anything like the thing
you were saying at the beginning uh
Israel's like you know they're talk they
they they bring up the beheading of
children example right like probably not
true uh in an effort to dehumanize it's
like it's like and if anything like
watching like seeing the paragliders or
like kill a bunch of concert goers like
that just makes the I think like gives
Israel Authority to dehumanize them even
more so I don't really see where the
phenon argument applies here they are
already his argument is they are already
dehumanized they already seen as only
animals they have only they've done they
tried the two-state solution they tried
the PLO they tried peaceful protests in
every case they got shot down literally
yeah I'm I'm not saying I'm not saying
that like uh there's a solution I'm just
saying that this is a good way to make
things way worse I don't think you can
argue on one hand that the Situation's
already terminal and then argue that
they also made it worse I think in in
the manikian universe that fenan is
describing here is also the universe of
the Cold War where you have capitalism
and socialism in the backdrop right but
but there isn't any of that anymore
right for us living in capitalist
societies who who are we told are the
evil ones right they tend to just be
isolated people like uh
you know North Korea Russia those sorts
of things right some sometimes Saudi
Arabia when they're not you know getting
along very well with the oil Lobby in
the states or those sorts of that
becomes evil right so what what is
calling somebody evil isn't you know
you're not in danger of pushing them
into some kind of uh communist sphere
we're not we're not you know worrying
about the we're not got this old United
States kind of Red Scare stuff going on
where the Communists are going to
infiltrate so the whole context is
completely different in that sense right
evil is something much more nebulous and
non-specific now well I think I think
also there's a there's a couple
different things too where I don't know
if the fenan I mean he's thinking about
it from the Algerian perspective too
where there's like a clear delineation
about like who are the indigenous people
and who aren't and and I think that
there I don't know enough to like be
sure about this but I think that there
are like some legitimate claims that you
know Jewish people are somehow like
ethnically like rooted in in that piece
of land and as are the Arabs so it's
like I don't think that there's like a
as clear a delineation between like who
is the indigenous who are like the true
indigenous populations like yes of
course I'm just saying it's more
complicated but clearly like I said on
the last episode I think there's good
reasons to think Israel is obviously an
apartheid state and there's a power
differential but I'm just saying that uh
in terms of of using the fenon framework
I don't know if it if it works perfectly
well I think like another thing is I'm
pretty sure he talks about being able to
overcome the colonizers with like you
know greater and greater arms but if you
face them um in like in a in a situation
where there's not really much chance of
that like I think in in in some places
he even says like there's a chance that
that could lead to another system of
exploitation that like it's not always
the case that that uh facing the
colonizer um with like if you don't have
basically I think talk uh like if you
just have bare minimum of arms and not
actually like enough to make a dent to
to get the colonizer to
realize uh your Humanity then you're not
actually going to be doing any good I
think that's absolutely right
because if if it is like a typical
Colonial situation like Algeria for
example the colonizer
if if it becomes too much work they can
just go off back home exactly they
can go home Israel there's where are the
Israelis going to go they don't have
another place to go but this it's more
like a North
American uh Colonial situation yes like
where where are we going to go they
don't they don't have
a yeah we go back to our whatever home
home ethnic country it you know is
Israel is is is sponsored by the US it's
that's not their
Metropolis their us is their sponsor but
in fenan situation it's clearly French
occupying it's clearly French occupied
yeah and and those people those so are
happy to go back to France like I mean
it's not or at least it's not as big of
a deal well I mean it's it's it's a
pretty big deal for for the for the
people who are you know drafted to go
over there no no what I mean is like is
like uh like pill said becomes too much
work there's a Homeland just go back to
France it's like yeah sure could we go
back to Europe I guess but that would be
like it's not the same as just like a
French soldier drafted okay just go back
to France like I don't know well that's
what I was saying is that there's not
going to be a onetoone application of
fenan to any mo any say more recent
situation because so much has changed
you know the not not least of which
being the end of the Cold War but also
the internet and media and how fast news
travels now and how how that can be you
know used as part of as part of a
strategy right the the emergence of the
sudden you know eruptions of violence
now can be very much capitalized on to
Garner support right as the media can
choose what to run and what not to run
and you know that that creat a bit of a
bias a bit of a problem already because
what what are you seeing in the news and
more importantly now what are you not
seeing because news travels really
quickly but what is being selected and
put in front of you that becomes a huge
question right so you know slow violence
violence that kind of just lingers under
the radar you know a kind of slow
squeezing out of people creating
conditions that are unlivable for them
and hoping that they'll leave like those
things aren't Sensational enough you can
do that sort of thing and fly under the
radar a little bit but when there's big
explosions of violence especially when
they serve some political purpose those
can then just be kind of flouted in
everybody's faces and whip everyone up
into a big frenzy over it and then
Garner support for some I don't know
some agenda or other I mean the list the
list would go on infinitely about the
differences between now and then when
when Fan's writing in this decolonial
situation where you actually have
the former British Empire falling to
pieces and and and and what's going to
what's the world going to be like after
that and I kind of disagree with you
Victor that this is suddenly worse to
flare up more violence is worse
because this would have happened
eventually like you can you can blame
the current Administration or
administration's past but this the
situation is unsustainable regardless
and eventually violence is the only act
that that takes any
significance but at least for Fan's
perspective he says uh like if the if
the inferiority of the colonized is an
assumption on both sides like the
colonized say the the gazin people say
we don't have a future we don't have a
promise we're not going to have a better
life
and the other side the Israelis say you
know what yeah we're not going to give
you a better life you're just going to
live and die in a state of occupation
then revolutionary violence is meant to
be a shock to the entire system it's
meant to be like a a to create a sense
of awareness to anyone who's listening
and I think it has succeeded on that
front to say we're really willing to die
and risk Our Lives for the possibility
of another future which is almost a
demand for recognition a recognition
that they wouldn't have got otherwise
that they they're they're going to die
anyway but I might as well I don't think
that's true as well I don't think it's
true that they were going to die anyway
I don't think it's true that there's
going to be a ground Invasion no matter
what they're going to die in a state of
occupation regardless of whether Hamas
is there they've been in a state of
occupation for well first of all who is
this they right like we're not even
talking about the Palestinian people
we're talking about Hamas
okay we're talking about a terrorist
organization like I think that's an
accurate an accurate we're talking about
the the the over 2.3 million people in
Gaza the two and a half they weren't the
but they weren't the ones who who who
who decided to engage in violence right
like so that's another way in which I
don't think that the I don't think that
the the parallel with with the fenan
because I think that what fenan had in
mind was like a much more
broad-based like resistance from regular
people right we're not just talking
about that's totally ridiculous never is
the entire populace on board with a VI
but I'm just saying I'm just saying when
you when you say like they you talk
about you talk about like I just think
it's it's better to not to specify right
like we're not talking about Palestinian
people in general well then talk about
other re talk about the revolution the
American Revolution it's not always a
it's always a population plus combatants
that's always what it's but well yeah
sure but but I mean if you look at
public opinion within both the West both
the West Bank and Gaza
like support for Hamas is was like quite
low below 50% in most cases so like who
are they speaking
for like with their violence they're
probably speaking for themselves that
the fact that they're willing to risk
their life for another future I'm
talking about yeah I know another a
future of Theocratic Muslim rule sure or
or just a future where they're not dogs
and
dehumanized systematically I'm
sympathetic with I'm I'm extremely
sympathetic with
like the Palestinian people having some
future I don't know how to get there I
don't have the solution I'm just saying
like having
Theocratic terrorists commit acts of
violence on your behalf is maybe like
not the best exemplification of like a
revolutionary spirit and what is
then I I don't have the answer they
tried all the other options they tried
appealing to the International Community
they tried peaceful protest it's like
there's one card left to play like
you're acting like
Hamas is not gazin who were born under o
occupation yeah I mean we'll see what
happens I mean there's going to be a
ground Invasion now there's going to be
like endless missile strikes it's going
to be uh yeah I'm sure it's going to
lead to a great future well no violence
yeah violence is not going to be the
answer in the
end right but I mean
you it's violence it's the whole thing
is a violent
situation there's everything's violent
terrible look look look like Netanyahu
is the worst he's like he's like a
right-wing crazy person and he's he's
like you know winning off the backs of
like the most reactionary like horrid V
like
political I guess
momentum um I mean it's a terrible
situation I'm not saying that like
Netanyahu was going to was going to lead
to you know some great solution but I
think maybe eventually there would be
like some I have no idea though it's
like one of the most complicated
situations in like geopolitics in terms
of Solutions in terms of like where is
the differential power it's not that
complicated in the sense that clearly
like Israel has uh is kind of in a
domineering position that's clear but
from a Solutions perspective I think
it's extremely complicated I have I have
no idea what the answer is I think in a
in a very direct way what fenan I think
is saying here when he says he talks
about these divides and this manikian
situation and what he says says near the
beginning is is looking at the
immediacies of the colonial context it
is clear that what divides this world is
first and foremost what species what
race one belongs to in the colonies the
economic infrastructure is also a super
structure now this is a very discussed
passage but I think basically what he's
saying is you know there's there's you
have these white Christian colonists and
you have the black and brown
Natives and I mean what what's what's it
going to turn
into do you have you now have a kind of
judeo-christian side versus the Islamic
side right and but that's not that's not
where we want the line to be drawn we
don't want a religious War that's the
problem I agree but that's such a it
that's such an easy simplification and
that's what the news kind of is good at
is is you know presenting
simplifications of of situation but it's
it can be very very dangerous at the
same time but I'm hearing I'm hearing
people who are like
sympathetic like I just think there's
also a simplification happening on the
like I agree with you um I think but I
think there's also a simplification
happening on people who want to be
sympath who are very sympathetic to the
Palestinian side a conflation of like
what Hamas is versus what Palestinian
people like actually want and that's
also a simplification if you're just
like okay this Hamas act well that's
just the people it's not it's not just
the people expressing their will it's a
fringe group oh yeah no you're acting
like violence I think that's part of the
simplification too like violence is
discriminate in terms of rational
response violence is after respon after
rational response has failed and every
rational response has failed like
there's no there's no there's no
reasoning with Israel on the case of so
let me let me just make really clear
where I agree with you and where I don't
where I agree with you is it's not
surprising that something like this
happened I agree that there's been like
the fires of this have been stoked I
would go further to say it's inevitable
that something like this would happen
cuz if you treat it's inevitable sure if
you treat people that way if you treat
people without measure without reason
inevitably they're going to do something
unreasonable God i s i sound really
dialectical but this is I don't
I don't disag I so I don't disagree with
you but where the part that I don't
agree with you on is that it's actually
going to
work like it's not going to do it's
going to make things worse it's it's
it's but like but okay but hold on why
are you why are you like all of a sudden
being like Oh well of course it's
inevitable but what's inevitable what's
the inevitable response from the Israeli
side like why are you discounting that
oh I think that is inevitable it's just
that I'm paying I'm paying for that
though it's a cycle it's a cycle as we
no but that's that's my only Point like
like but it's just like when you when
you add this F sort of my
representatives are representing me in
terms of favorability towards that
dis of course it's going to be a disp
that's what I meant when I said things
are going to get way worse it's going to
be a way disproportionate response from
the Israeli side I'm not saying that
from the perspective of like well then
these you know these irrational like
like homos agents who are like acting
involv no I understand that they're just
acting in in in they're reacting to the
situation
that's bad but but I'm not but but I
feel like there's an edge of like
celebratory like oh this is like an
expression of like what fenon describes
as resistance you know it's going to
create it's going to make them feel like
they gain more subjectivity like I think
that's all it's just going to
make things worse because we know what
the predictable response of is of the
Israelis like we were talking about
different situation that they don't have
somewhere to go back to like the
Algerian situation so the solution like
it being part of a solution Maybe like
100 steps down the line this maybe but I
think like there 100 steps down the line
something's going to happen eventually
um I just don't agree that this is like
oh this is like going to lead to
something better like no I think it's
going to we have every reason to think
it's going to lead to the situation
being way worse so fenan in this reading
draws this very important distinction of
like people will die they will sacrifice
their life in a suicidal way even for a
shred of dignity now I don't know if
he's right on that or not I'm not a
psychiatrist he is so I'm kind of
willing to defer on that and in the case
of something like completely separate
but uh the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising right
uh there was a Survivor from the Warsaw
Ghetto Uprising who
said we knew that we were going to die
we knew this would not be
successful but we owed it to our dignity
to we our Our Lives had been dictated by
the Germans in every case thus far we
wanted to choose we did this because we
wanted to choose how we would die and I
this is a this is a context that's
absolutely foreign to our experience
obviously I don't want to just like drop
it in there and Transplant like I
understand it but I think fenon at least
does understand that that there's a a
case to be made for dying with some
dignity to not die without hope and that
if someone's willing to do that to die
then you have to ask what the what are
the situa what's the situation what are
the contingencies that made that the
best
option yeah and I I think I think even
Fan's really just tracking the
development of a national Consciousness
and and saying violence contributes to
that Awakening of a Consciousness I
don't think he's saying like that's the
best way to do it this is good or bad
he's just seems to be tracking this sort
of development almost in the in the same
sort of veilance as as proletarian class
Consciousness right like if you're
having similar experiences you're going
to develop a kind of collective
Consciousness eventually and and and
maybe unfortunately those will come
through violent struggles for freedom
and survival right but it does create a
kind of national Consciousness that if
we get bogged down in like these who's
speaking for who kind of scenarios then
we'll never really is we're trying we're
trying to make sense of that and that's
not I don't think that's something we're
going to be able to do as as a situation
is unfolding but I think it's
undeniable that violence brings
attention violence creates a kind of at
least a perceived kind of unity even if
it's not real or not total or there's
many people who disagree and diverge
from that and and even at the end once
that class Consciousness once that s
sorry National Consciousness emerges he
says it's nothing but a crude empty
fragile shell it could it could go right
back to kind of tribalism right it
doesn't necessarily then lead to a
progressive better future like
everything is always hanging in the
balance in situations like these and
there's there's too many contingencies
to make statements like that I think
he's just positing that you know in
these situations which are just
inherently violent there's a national
Consciousness Dynamic and that's kind of
he seems to be going through it in
dialectical fashion you know okay the
colonizers dehumanize the colonized okay
now something happens to the colonized
what happens to them there's an
internalization there's a kind of Envy
there's a projection almost of a utopian
State now onto the colonized communities
who live in a in abundance and wealth
and they extract the resources and use
the use the country's you know in that
sort of way so he's and then he goes
back and forth then what does that
create now now the colonizers are aware
that they're being looked at in this way
and like there's he he sort of does this
back and forth dialectical movement and
he's just tracking this sort of
situation and this developments and he
yeah he eventually gets to the point you
know where once a violent situation is
now going to emerge what happens is then
the Bourgeois class the colonizers will
turn to the colonized and say hey what
about like Universal human values right
you should peacefully protest like don't
commit these acts of violence so now
we're talking down to the colonized
people saying you should adopt these VI
these because violence is bad and you
shouldn't do it right you should take
our again and then he goes back to the
colonized side I'm sorry I'm just
jumping around but then he
goes I think this appes to ignore these
values they they mock these values
because they're obviously being deployed
in a very instrumental And Timely way in
order to you know assuage the fear of
the colonizers at the at an uprising
right like there's these sort of very
particular motives and this very kind of
this unconscious development right like
I I I have a hard time just like reading
this and then being like Oh yeah fenan
was totally down with violence like it
just seems so much more complicated than
that but we hear these no stories all
like people are invoking fenan to
justify the violence it's like what okay
what where's the quote for that I
where's the analysis like it's just
totally out of context yeah we take this
seriously because that's what the
media kind of delivers to our feeds and
then we react to it right this is
actually a circumstance where I feel
like using Theory it's I'm surprised
pills that you're like this maybe is
where a theory matters like cuz if
anything I would say like appealing to
the theory of anon just confuses things
like if you're trying to apply it to
Israel Palestine I just I think it's
actually a good circumstance where
Theory just isn't helpful at all well I
think it would take a it would be
helpful to step back and learn some
things like do some careful studying
it's not like having theory in your
pocket and then whip it out the moment
anything happens right like I have a
dairy do quote for what just happened oh
now I have something else for that like
no it's like step back like unplug for a
second to get your mind straight and
like do some research like but that's
not but but again we just like let
social media kind of just roll in and
Define the situations and all the
positions for us and that and yeah we
let that happen that does happen and it
and it just creates this this complete
confusion right toally
is going down on the left and the right
is is you know chastising the moderate
rights and they're sniping each other
who's more like the competition in the
among the Republicans is like who is the
most behind Israel now right that's the
position that the the candidate wants to
so they snipe each other if they feel
like they're a little bit hesitant to
support Israel right like it just
creates this total confusion and
it's and
it that's what theory can do as long as
you step back for a second well that's
the problem the problem I think is like
if you have like this fof framework and
you have it and then you look at a
situation you're like well I'm just
going to plug in this situation into the
fof framework when really I think you
should start by just like reading the
history and looking into the specificity
of the situation and then maybe you
could be like well maybe it's F helpful
as opposed to having the the I don't I
don't I I think I think again I I go
back to the the original pills uh ideas
the the doesn't matter
here well as I've been trying to say I
think the the utility of phenon here is
the notion that violence is
equivocal I think if anything fenon is
too hopeful or his his definition of
colonialism doesn't work here because in
a colonial situation the colonizers
actually need the colonized for their
labor and in this exact in Zionist
settler colonialism the only purpose is
actually just to get rid of them so we
can have a an ethnos State precisely but
that that would that would make it even
more to the point that there is no
speaking back the colonized cannot speak
back so there's this there's this this
is one of the most um of quoted passages
of this is that he says colonialism is
not a thinking machine or a body endowed
with reasoning faculties it is violence
in its natural state and it will only
yield when confronted with greater
violence so when he says something like
colonialism is not a thinking machine
you know we have these these State
sanctioned companies in you know 18th
century uh 17th century they're seeking
out profits they don't see the the
natives that they arrive upon as as
people they see natural resources and
then a source of Labor so they exploit
the the people get the resources send
them back home everybody makes money and
then there's like a a new class
definition here but in the case of I
guess Israel occupation it is very much
a thinking machine he says it's not like
colonialism doesn't think this is a
thinking machine this is a
plan um carried out by you know you
could not not Israel in general but by
in part particular the current regime
has very much a plan understanding the
logic and rationalities that are going
to produce the end it wants which is no
more
Palestinians so I I would I would
concede only on that point if you want
to say this is not actually a colonial
situation but this would mean it's worse
I mean I mean yeah I I agree it's worse
but he does say that it's kind of
characterized by one person one one side
replacing the other he he does say it's
not really about you know holding
somebody inthrall infinitely it's it's
about replacement it's about he says one
species a race which in quotes you know
replacing the other one and so it is I
mean that's what we would sort of call
the the language of ethnic cleansing he
like colonialism is sort of about that
in a way right and so no no conciliation
is possible in in within a a colonial
framework work yeah I mean I think I
think it's just and I think that that
crucial difference that uh why it's not
really I agree it's a worse situation
right like I think that's what makes it
more complicated and way harder to
imagine an end to right it's I mean it's
I almost feels like there's like an
Israeli realism here kind of like
capitalist realism it's I just can't
imagine you know uh a kind of world
without uh like I can't imagine how it
could end right like I just it's so
difficult and that's another reason why
um even though as I've acknowledged I
understand why a Hamas would would end
up uh engaging in in a violent act and
and perhaps other groups in Palestine
I'm sure will right in the future but
that's why I'm just I just don't see
anything to celebrate here in terms of
oh it's going to maybe lead to something
better because the situation is
different than a normal Colonial
situation it it's like you said it's a
thinking entity uh there there's a plan
there's an entrenchment it's just going
to make things way worse I'm not saying
that they they should be rational and
think about that and be like well then I
won't engage because it's going to be
worse I'm not making a normative claim
here about like what they should have
done differently I'm just making I just
feel sad about it because it's just
going to make things way whereas more
people are going to die more people are
going to lose family members it's just
going to be way worse I I don't I don't
see any reason to be like oh yeah oh my
God they're going to realize and the
Israelis are going to see them as like
you know more real people and and
they're going to no it's the the
War drums are are pounding hard
and loud as and it's going to be
horrible I don't want to go so far as to
say that like so so as to forget that
there are Israelis opposed to that
genocide
project that said there's another thing
that fan could not have for seen because
he's doing some phenomen phenomenology
of spirit this intera action where
people look each other in the
face and you force yourself to be seen
and recognized but through the
technological mediation at least the
surveillance is total but
technological Gins don't interact with
even police or soldiers they interact
with walls or or speakers or a
surveillance camera or drones it's
absolutely inhuman like even this is
where I would think this is even more
depressing than than fenan could have
imagined is that there's no possibility
to even be recognized it's just
indiscriminate Anonymous misery Forever
Without promise and without
hope so it's hard for me to see anything
but a reaction of violence emerging from
a situation like that indiscriminate
violence even yeah I don't disagree I
just don't think it's anything to be
happy about or like hopeful about I
don't you keep saying that people are
happy and hopeful I've never I don't
know who these people are unless you
just what do you mean what do you mean
the statement the literal
statement was like that we were talking
about at the beginning was like oh my
God they engaged in an act of like
resistance and like we fully support
them it's like well they did do that no
one should be happy about that they did
engage in an act of resistance futile as
it may
be sure well but okay you were saying
like who's celebrating it like I I
detected celebratory tone in that
statement if that's the case I think
uh I just think I just think I just
thought it was a kind of 1980s
ironic I mean it's
not it's not a good
look I feel like you want to say
something pills I feel like you got you
got a thought at the tip of your tongue
but you're not sure no I'm just trying
to look through my notes like if if
you're if you're saying that this is
worse then I don't know it was it was
already worse this was faded to happen
yeah like I'm not disagreeing with you
about that right like I'm I'm saying I'm
not surprised like fan Fan's
understanding of this is like when when
someone is absolutely pushed to the
Limit he says like he says you're going
to have stochastic violence not from the
integrated people not for not for the
people that are involved in the
political discussion you could say the
the Palestinian Authority for example
completely neutered they're trying to
engage in a political
solution and they're seen as basically
traitors and for fenan it's going to be
stochastic violence that is
indiscriminate that emerges from outside
the class system entirely from outside
the bureaucracy entirely because the
bureaucracy is managed by the colonizer
and that that
externality that other of the system is
going to be the first to discover that
only violence communicates or only
violence has a cash value it's the only
thing with an exchange value so I I kind
of am just
wondering where you think this is either
celebratory or whether you think where
you think that violence is not the only
answer cuz what is the other one
I've already said that I have no idea
how to solve this situation like I I I
literally and I would never presume to
so then how do you know that it's wrong
how do you know which is the right and
wrong version of communication because
okay in the same way that you know that
it's inevitable that the Palestinians or
whoever are going to react to that
situation I know that the isra Israelis
the Israeli state which is I don't know
maybe a thousand has a thousand times or
a million times more resources and have
no intention of leaving
like I like you should know that they're
also going to react in a way
disproportionate way like I just it's
just I don't understand what's not clear
about that you're ending the chain of
causation with Israeli response because
I think but of course it's going to
respond because we're we're we're oldish
right we I remember the responses to uh
2008 and
2014 and our politicians including our
quote unquote aggressive politicians are
still Towing the same line but I don't
think anyone's falling for it anymore
and even if that's the case I mean I do
I mean I do think that like real the
case that it's even moving the needle
then you have to say that Hamas was
successful but who who says it's going
to move the needle like that's that's a
presumption that's I mean that's I don't
have evidence I mean with Nan yaho in
power and like more anger about this
like I just don't I don't know man like
like I I'm I I think my assumption about
the causal chain here is just that it's
going to lead to further escalation
that's like in the near and medium term
okay like and then beyond that we are
just being extremely speculative like
okay like maybe it'll maybe it'll like
do something I just I don't see it look
like my I mean hundreds of hundreds of
American Jews like holding a sit in and
getting arrested in Congress that seems
like something different what do you
mean I don't I don't know I I actually
don't know what you're referring to they
held a sit in at Congress for what
purpose in protest of what of the
Israeli occupation oh yeah
sure why are you all of the sudden so
optimistic about that these things can
make a difference cuz you're so adamant
that it's not making any difference and
I'm saying there has been no difference
made
for uh I mean honestly like it like
again I feel uncomfortable like getting
into the de like the details since I'm
not that educated on the internal
politics of Israel but it seems to me
that the the most likely change probably
has to happen within the Israeli
government like there needs to be some
like I think it's ultimately going to be
up to the political will of like maybe
left-wing Israelis to fight for maybe a
multiethnic one state
democracy uh like like South like a
South Africa situ except in in in this
case it would be like a 50/50 because
about the populations of Israelis versus
Palestinians about 50 I mean I don't
know like that seems like maybe violence
on the Palestinian side continued
violence could help further that but My
worry is just that it's also just as
likely it's just as likely that that's
just going to further entrench the
right-wing crazy Netanyahu
fascistic side within Israeli politics
to doesn't seem like the case I think
there's he's got like 8 85% disapproval
at this point so oh yeah okay good I
mean good so well I mean I think I think
we can say things are changing things
are happening it's just we're just
getting bogged down on on one very
specific event right like I mean again I
I just have to defer and say go listen
to something Chomsky said recently about
this right I mean like the biggest thing
he'll point out most
recently is the way that you know Israel
has kind of been thumbing its nose at at
at the states recently right like you
had kind of the Trump Administration and
they completely cow toow to they gave
Israel anything they wanted and up until
not long ago you
know Israel would kind of do what the
Americans said right like they wouldn't
they're not beholden to them but they
would still listen and and we still
think that might be the cas case right
if if the US would just stop giving them
billions of dollars every year if the US
would just actually say something then
maybe something would change but they're
clearly intent on being completely
permissive and abiding by anything that
and so that's a good point that's what's
different now is that there's a chance
that Israel even is now going to cut
ties with the us or at least now start
openly defying them which then means
okay less control like now we can't you
know even even if we do pressure our
governments to you know say stop it
which is in itself very unlikely that
people can get together because of all
of this discussion that's really
just demonstrated even Among Us that we
can't agree so imagine now now scale
that up to the whole population so not
probably not going to happen but it
that's what's going to be different in
the future and that's I mean that's what
again I'm just trying to keep on
illustrating that focusing on
you know this like a chess match okay
their move what are they going to do
like you're missing a huge like overview
of the situation that again people like
jsky or if you watch democracy now you
get a bit of it although you know
they're a bit
moralizing sometimes for my taste I
agree with you Eric you get a big
overview and that's but that's not what
the mainstream media conversation looks
like what the mainstream media
conversation looks like right now is
Israel is at war with Hamas and that's
the end of the story no mention of
Palestine no mention of history no
mention of anything else that's the only
thing that we're supposed to focus on
according to most of the mainstream
outlets and and that seems to be it I
agree with you about the US I think like
so if we're talking about what's likely
to change
things um like us cutting funding so
like political will in fact every single
country in the world I think in the UN
except Israel and the United States
endorse a two-state solution like as
official policy so like okay the US
withdraws its support withdraws their
billions of dollars that could make a
difference guess what happened in
response to this Biden just had a speech
yesterday committing to funding both the
the Ukraine war and the Israeli War yeah
great that violence really really worked
well there to to to further that yeah I
mean it didn't H well it didn't stop
what was already happening which is a
constant but but they committed even
more they're they're doubling down it's
just yeah well yeah I mean yeah and
that's taxpayer money so that's you know
telling people you know your tax dollars
are going to fund this horrific thing
right honestly you're like now that I'm
thinking about it your better chance of
making changes like you need basically
like like strong political coalitions
within the United States and within
Israeli politics ICS to basically try to
put a stop to the to the money and the
funding that's where you're going to see
uh you're going to probably see like
your best chance of getting some real
meaningful change and I think that the
problem the problem with yeah that's
like those are the that's the biggest
levers those are the just they just
vetoed a un proposal that Brazil put on
the table to call for a ceasefire and
they're voting on it and the US vetoed
the ceasefire exactly so actively they
are actively promoting this situation
well exactly exactly because the
violence authorizes it ceasefires are
anti-semitic sure yeah I mean whatever
the rhetoric you want to throw at it is
like okay but that's what happened and
so we can see a sort of permissiveness
coming
from you know America and and many other
countries aren't really going to go
against what the US is doing and if the
UN mechanism fails and even I think I'm
the feel like I'm the only one who's
like being a kind of like structural
realist here about what's going to
happen like I feel like there can be a
slippage on to like to some sort of
Romanticism about like violence like
that it's going to like like some
radical laring about like what viol the
promise of violence I understand from a
realist kind of structuralist
perspective why people in in Gaza are
going to there's going to be bursts of
violence but I think like geopolitically
structurally like I just don't see any
reasonable argument for like how it's
going to lead to a short or medium-term
like better situation well the cynical
response is that we're going to see this
on Twitter for a while then something
will calm down and then we'll just
forget about it but the non- cynical
response is that by
provoking Israel by doing something that
is terrifying horrifying that's idealism
by doing that and by forcing them to
just bomb churches hospitals apartment
buildings then people see those images
that
can maybe not now maybe not in the near
future but when the geriatric ruling
class of our of our countries is out of
the way uh because they will die
inevitably this is also F that's
possible that's possible but it's alsoit
IDE on the table so I think the most
likely response is that we just forget
about it and uh go back to Taylor Swift
dating that that foot
football player but also I don't think
that uh I I don't think that there's
been such a swell in
2014 or 200 was it 8 or six anyway every
every cycle that this happens I don't
think there's been that swell of support
I mean I I I will say I I will say I am
genuinely like I am actually a little
bit
surprised by like I knew that for geopol
political
reasons us uh Canada like all these
other places would kind of be like
pro-israel but I will say I was actually
surprised by exactly how pro-israel they
were like I I I was even a little bit
like oh wow like like yeah this is
mask off of progressive yeah I I
was I was surprised I thought I thought
they would I thought they would be a
little bit more like measured or they
would be supportive but kind of like tep
or in their support they would include
some kind of statement about like they
were about like you know what's going to
happen to Palestinian civilians and
stuff like that or something like that
right but I was I was actually surprised
that which makes me actually just more
scared for how much worse it's going to
be I mean what what this kind of just
tells me maybe is that they've been pro-
Israel like that all along and they've
just never had to make a
decision that is an either or decision
right they could always kind of just
pursue their policies and have that but
now it's very forced now the the choice
is being forced it's like you know the
situation is very visible we're asking
politicians to make statements or or do
things about it and they're revealing
they're showing their cards a little bit
right like they've been like this all
along right like again what Chomsky will
say is is is everything changed and what
was it when when the occupation started
which was what like H 1967 or something
like that and and and suddenly it was
very a republican pro-israel situation
you know Evangelical Christians and the
and the American right and especially
within the last 20 years right like
netanyahu's strategy has gone from you
know being moderate and making overtures
to moderate America to now like openly
appealing to very right-wing America
he's he's a he's a smart politician and
he knows how to appeal to the states
right and that's and he's playing those
cards now
and I mean I'm not saying it was like
that all along it's there's a lot of
opportunism involved as well right and
we're not dealing with Hive
Minds here right you know if you have a
powder keg situation all it takes is one
person to light the match for the whole
thing to blow up even no matter
how many people didn't want it no matter
how many people did want it or didn't
want it it just takes one match right
and and and then some horrific
development and then suddenly you know
you're all on the same side of a
situation maybe with people that you
don't want to be on the same side with
but unfortunately you don't really get a
choice in how the media tends to
represent you and how you're discussed
either in the UN or in any individual
countries Parliament or whatever you
don't get that choice so you just have
to kind of live with the consequences or
die by the consequences very
unfortunately it it does get split into
sides that you never predicted cuz like
like I said I would expect progressives
to understand you know the especially a
differential of force in this case but
some of the people that are coming out
Pro Palestine you know Andrew
Tate newly newly converted
Muslim Glenn Greenwald didn't know what
happened to him but he's he's back on uh
Alexander Dugan Alexander Duan is pro
Palestine oh I guess big time he's just
uh he's just anything the Jews do right
and it was it was really funny to see
Michael millerman who you know uh if you
remember who that is was like the UFT
student who wanted to study uh Dugan
he's Jewish and I saw him tweeting he
was like you know Dugan is like a great
thinker but I don't always agree with
him on
everything and he was posting his thing
about being like like Pro Hamas and you
know contributing to like multipolarity
by trying to overthrow Israel oh yeah
that budget was 4 billion to Israel and
and 16 billion to the Ukraine or
something like that so of course you've
put you know that kind of in a way puts
Russia and Palestine in the same basket
very strangely so of course you know
there's there's a natural that's that's
less than I that's that's um less than
what I heard I heard that they're
sending 61 million to Ukraine and 10.6
billion to Israel oh I heard 4 billion
and then 16 billion I think it's 4
billion a year already but no any and
then 16 billion to the Ukraine war you
put you put Russia and and Palestine in
the same being not funded by the United
States baset so you're going to create a
weird opportunity in that case he sent a
he sent an emergency funding package to
Congress I think I just saw Glenn
Greenwald um tweeting about it it's like
61 to to is to Ukraine 10.6 to Israel 9
billion to humanitarian Aid in all of
those places uh 12 billion for Border
agents and then 7.4 billion to Taiwan
and other Pacific
allies yeah it creates a
weird it draws a weird line through all
these
situations yeah well the system the
point I guess is that it forces a
decision and then
those those uh decision makers that you
would have figured would be on one side
of this or on the other I've I don't
know what he said but there's some some
Twitter people very upset with Bernie
Sanders for example on this what did he
say I don't I'm not sure yeah the future
is is radically
uncertain no I agree I mean I think the
system's Theory point is actually strong
with these things because I think it
just clarifies why people and why agents
are doing the things that they're doing
right it's just like and most of them
are not doing anything these are perform
they're performative speech acts they
take place on the internet I decry I
allow I permit whether we say that or
not no one gives a it doesn't move
the needle but the question really is
though like what you're saying is what
moves the needle you're saying this is
this is worse or will be worse I think I
I think it's going to make things worse
I mean that's that's based on the power
differential based on the fact that
Israel is not it's not a colonial
situation and the way the way that fenan
describes it's it's a it's more
complicated they're more there's it's
more entrenched they've got nowhere to
leave right like they've got endless
money the horrifying anti-humanist point
is like yeah it takes it takes lives to
change these things in a situation of
just total violence like f said I don't
see that's the thing where it does take
it take words words have not worked
they've tried words for a long time it
didn't work so the last sort of
communication is to give up your own
life even just to force people to wonder
why did you give your life for this yeah
that I mean that point sure yeah it's
anti-humanist I understand why it would
sound totally offensive but it's the
it's the way that every revolution has
ever happened
including the successful
ones yeah I mean I think revolutions
require like for them to be successful
require radically different conditions
and also like Buy in from that's the
thing like like I said you know again
I'm not ascribing rational actor to
anyone like I understand that these are
just like reactions but the attention
should be like Israeli politics and
American politics like that's where
you're most likely to move the needle
speaking of needles I'm always reminded
of the funny needle when I read Chomsky
of the um what is it the uh the Doomsday
Clock and uh because he's he's very fond
of referencing where that's at and and
with the with the war in the Ukraine at
the beginning of the year they had
already moved it to 90 seconds to
midnight and I imagine now it's even
closer because yeah well there's nuclear
weapons unfortunally involved in this is
so weird well it's yeah it's the the you
know we should do an episode about it I
don't understand what the purpose of it
is well they're warning they they set
the set it to warn people about how
close we are to nuclear Annihilation
right and so when there's Wars going on
they tend to you know so this is another
War that's started up since they've
moved it to 90 Seconds To Midnight which
is quite close historically and uh so
it's probably even closer now and uh
yeah new nuclear weapons being involved
in the situation also make things much
more dangerous and comp at I feel like
God I feel like our our patreon is just
going to hate me after
this and I don't know why cuz like all
I'm I'm not making any normative
statements I'm literally just saying
like my own I think I'm being like the
most cynical structuralist here about
about this and like I think that uh I
actually think surprisingly pills has
been a little bit of an
idealist well I hope we've I I hope
we're I gave you the cynical respon
discussing no no I agree maybe maybe
maybe you've moved over a little bit I
hope we I encourage disagreement well
I'll end my point at least with with one
quotation this manism reaches its
logical conclusion and dehumanizes the
colonized subject in Plain Talk he is
reduced to the state of an animal and
we've heard that haven't we consequently
when the colonist speaks of the
colonized he uses Zoological terms but
the colonized know they are not animals
and at the very moment when when they
discover their Humanity they begin to
sharpen their weapons I mean I I did
find some of the statements that fan
made quite
uh yeah out of context they do reflect
the kind of rhetoric being thrown
around I mean I think I think that maybe
even the the leanians will be better
than us because they understand the the
power of retroactivity and and how you
know this this event is going to appear
in a completely different light in the
future who knows depending whatever the
whatever the future brings that's going
to bring with it a different past as
well and we have to keep aware of that
right alongside our pathetic ability to
predict anything is that the fact that
the future tends to also alter the past
retroactively and that just adds another
layer to it um yeah so here's a quote
that I found that I think is maybe uh
it was from like another article that I
was reading about this the militant who
faces the colonialist war machine with
bare minimum of arms realizes that while
he's breaking down Colonial oppression
he's building up yet another system of
exploitation this discovery is
unpleasant bitter and sickening and yet
everything seemed so simple before I
remember that yeah there's some lines
like that in there that complicate the
very simplistic you know fenan was Pro
violence kind of view and I think that
is a mistaken View he's very much a
dialectical thinker about
this that's like uh yeah when you
succeed I mean this is kind of your your
concern and your main concern is if you
succeed with overthrowing the oppressor
then what are you left
with that too and if you've done it if
you've done it in the name of like uh
radical Jihad then you know the
situation following that is not going to
be necessarily better but but again I
say we're still on we're still on the
first turn of the dialectic we're not on
the second turn of the dialectic think
of macelli's advice to the prince even
right like once all the violence is done
you know he advises the prince you you
know whoever you commit violence against
you better get them all because if you
don't they're going to come for you
they're going to go into hiding they're
going to build up a following and
they're going to come back and kill you
right like f i mean of course macavelli
is in in Exile and trying to appeal to
the medich with this book to try and get
let back into Florence and so he's
jurries out whether Mackie believed what
he wrote but that's his advice as as a
as a skilled States person he probably
knows what he's talking about and uh
yeah I mean that's violence be gets
violence right again you know it can
suddenly turn you think you're on the
side of justice and then you're faced
with a new horrific situation that
you've now created that's dialectics
baby unsatisfying
but yeah but maybe maybe a little closer
to real exactly it was pretty uncensored
so we'll see I I wonder what kind of
reaction we're going to get for this one
but it's not going to make a huge it's
not gonna make any difference either way
oh God I'm never gonna I'm never gonna
work
again I mean I don't know I feel like I
feel like my only point should be so is
so uncontroversial I'm just like yeah
things are probably going to get worse
like that's literally like at its most
simple my point I know I'm just waiting
for the the before they get better part
that never seems to come I just don't
even see a path for that but yeah and
there's always the chance of retrograde
motion the inertia is all going in One
Direction so I don't know like anything
to slow the inertia I don't know what
that is because our
Representatives don't represent us but
when yeah and this is this is like the
systems theory most accurate and also
most depressing point is that you can't
do anything as an individual to change
that inertia the only thing that could
change and this is even idealistic to
say this public opinion changing if it
were to you might eventually see results
in a political system down the line but
we already know that our political
system get beholden to
special interests in our country in
America and even if public opinion did
shift which would be a needle move I
will say it'll be it would be a needle
move but even if it happened that
doesn't mean that anything else will
happen you saying it's going to get
worse I think the inertia is going in
One Direction anyway which is uh
genocide and
eradication and if that's the end and as
long as that is The Faded end of the
current course and all the decisions
that led up to this point I don't know
what you mean by worse that more will
die from missiles instead of toxic
drinking water I don't I don't know but
I don't think it can be worse I mean I
think maybe I have uh I I agree with
that I also think that you know maybe
it's worth paying more attention to uh
the Israeli left though I've I've been
told that by some people like you should
just pay attention to what they're doing
because like I said if like the best
places to move the needle are probably
within Israel and within the United
States in terms of funding not dealing
with Hive m
exactly no that's an important Point
Eric to keep emphasizing just to
exemplify just how this world is
like I'm just noticing Tucker Carlson's
show on Twitter like right now it's like
well you'll be shocked to learn this but
it turns out the whole George Floyd
story was a lie and it's like it's like
what the is this world coming to
yeah what is he gonna say he's saying
that like he wasn't he's like and I'm
seeing it cuz it's coming up in
subtitles and it's like he wasn't
murdered at all we all think that guy in
prison murdered him but he wasn't and
it's like I have no idea what evidence
he's offering or anything but I mean I
assume it's going to be I'm
shocked that someone would say that
pictures have resurfaced of uh George
Floyd hanging out in the Bahamas oh my
God is that the the he's hanging out
with
Tupac yeah Tupac and Elvis and all of
them all right well this has been just a
barrel of laughs
boys um any any final thoughts from you
guys
God I feel like I just saw a poll come
up in on Twitter I don't know if this is
like change but apparently like on the
question of should us send weapons and
supplies to Israel it's like pretty
bipartisan that it's like 5050 like
about about 50% of Republicans think
that that they should and 50% of
Democrats think that they should oh only
50 on
Republican 57% Republican 47% uh
Democrats so it's a 10% difference but
still closer than I would have thought
yeah some I mean I'd call that
manufactured consent I don't know Eric
keeps bringing up uh Chomsky on this
point yeah I know for sure I mean I I
I'm not I'm not saying I disagree with
that well fenan said they would sort of
um you have the more uh the the more
Progressive people in the uh colonial
government once um you know the the
native intellectuals and and and and
people start joining in in into the
government government and then you have
the more radical people and they tend to
get
isolated and uh then kicked out and so
there's almost like a progress you know
it's like what the the the leftist camp
in the democratic government in the US
right now right we're all very aware of
who they are they've been very much
isolated at least singled out and that's
a danger right if but they might also
you know create a movement within the
party and bring it in a more Progressive
Direction
again we never know these things but
there's a big likelihood that they'll
just be shut out the progressive voices
will get shut out and the uh more uh
right-leaning Democrats will win over
who knows that is our unsolicited our
unsolicited submission to the void and
we went long nothing will come of it so
it's not really consequential either way
just going to dox myself after this just
to get ahead of
it
all right well guys uh no place to end
it but that's where we're going to end
it
yep thanks for listening despondency
good note to end
on shit's Grim man shit's
[Music]
grim